this is the lg tone free fp9 it boasts a
slew of intuitive features such as
active noise cancelling plug-in wireless
and its very special uv nano charging
case which helps sanitize your earbuds
in just five minutes that's fast
this is the cleanest pair of earbuds
money can buy
literally what's up my fellow geeks
zacky here back for something that
requires your attention so listen up
because today we will be taking a deeper
look into lg's flagship true wireless
noise cancelling earbuds the lg tone
free fp9
these days there are many companies who
want to be heard in so many ways so you
see many versions of this one thing but
believe me you haven't seen something
like this
now i've had this earbuds for a while
now and this has been my daily driver
when i'm at the gym in the office or
even gaming and this pair of earbuds
have performed beyond my expectations
alright how well let's dive right into
it but before that do give this video a
thumbs up and subscribe it goes a long
way and keeps us doing what we love so
let's start with the build quality and
design from the charging case to the bus
themselves these are small enough to
carry around and they don't stick out
like a sore thumb each earbud offers the
same matte design as the case with a
glossier metallic strip where the
gesture controls are located i really
enjoy the short stems here as they
negate the clicking and clicking for
those who wear earrings or ear studs so
that is a plus right there you've also
got a conker shape designed on the
earbuds to help achieve a more snug fit
they also come with medical grade
hypoallergenic ear gels which are very
comfortable to wear and it also reduces
the risk of skin irritation around the
ear canal the earbuds here are light
weight weighing a mere 5.2 grams each
with the earbuds being very secure and
i've never felt them come loose or even
slipping out during my runs or even at
the gym now speaking of which these
earbuds
are ipx4 rated so when it comes to sweat
or getting caught in the rain these
earbuds should not give you any issues
whatsoever and with this earbuds you do
get gesture controls as well and all you
need to do is to gently tap either side
of these earbuds to play stop next track
previous track and the like now you are
able to remap the touchpad settings with
the lg tone free app so you have some
customization options there now the best
part about the tone free is the charging
case and it's like a little macaron
shaped box and you would have any issues
fitting this into your pockets the case
is well built and the buds are closely
fitted inside the case you won't hear
any rattling with this even with
the rigorous street test
now of course what this device has that
no other in the market offers is
cleanliness and hygiene and we have
talked about the uv nano technology
which is the standout feature for those
who are concerned about hygiene now i
for one
get skin irritation after wearing
earbuds for extended periods of time you
know like when you get hot air after
humid day and you just start to scratch
that off footage but the more you
scratch the more you itch yeah not with
this bad boy fun fact your earbuds have
2 700 times more bacteria than a kitchen
cutting board so now that you know that
please do not share your earbuds
so anyway with the uv nano technology
this kills 99.9 percent of bacteria on
the speaker mesh of the earbuds in just
five minutes while charging the case
thing is you aren't able to sanitize the
earbuds on the go though and you will
have to hook up the provided usb
charging cable to the case to activate
the uv nano feature which if you think
about it it's not a big deal to be
honest and after a day of use i find
myself charging the case anyway so you
will have a clean pair of earbuds pretty
much every day simply put these earbuds
out germ-free after each charge when you
take it back out a fully charged case
will provide you up to 24 hours of total
playtime with active noise cancelling
turned off and up to 15 hours with anc
turned on earbuds wise you have a decent
10 hours of playback with anc turned off
and 6 hours with anc turned on and on
top of all that it also has quick
charging support with an hour worth of
playback with just 5 minutes of charging
another one of its main features is the
ability to connect your traditional 3.5
mm jack on your devices and stream audio
directly to the fp9 yes you've heard me
this pair of wireless earbuds offer
unique wired setup that is performance
changing so say you like to connect this
to your dual sense controller on your
playstation 5 you can plug the charging
case with its provided usb c to aux
cable directly to the controller and
have audio directly from your
playstation in your butts without using
bluetooth did that make sense i think
that makes sense yeah that makes sense
with that being said i've never seen
this before in other true wireless
earbuds and it's a very cool feature
that i'm sure will help a lot of folks
who will want to wirelessly connect two
devices without bluetooth at this point
there are a lot of standout features
coming from the fb9 but how does it
perform in terms of sound quality
wow
glad you might ask because these earbuds
sound exceptionally well the lows here
are bassy but does not drown out the
finer details in music and you will
enjoy the gravity in the mid-range
frequencies while the higher frequencies
are also pretty much distinguishable in
clarity now overall i gotta say this is
a fun pair of earbuds to use the vocals
in your music are gonna sound extra
juicy and for those bass hits out there
you will not be disappointed of course
with lg's partnership with meridian
these earbuds are also engineered for
better audio profile but you do have
some customization and presets available
in the lg tone free app now the fp9 has
five distinct audio profiles two of them
are catered to the eq which is bass
boost and treble boost now the remaining
three are catered to spatial processing
which alters the sound staging you can
also set two custom eq presets to your
liking however i found that the default
bass boost preset to be the one i use
the most
because i'm a base hit i love the bass
it's all about the bass baby all about
their base okay however the 3d sound
stage preset is enjoyable particularly
when streaming movies and shows the bass
you get so much bass on this and of
course it's like a movie like sound
staging which i enjoy it's kind of like
kind of like imax like the imx
experience with the rumble effects and
the bullets whistling exposures blowing
up so i gotta say it's really effective
and i'm quite surprised by the tuning
done by meridian see the thing here is
that most earbuds that come with preset
apps don't do much but each of the
presets here on the fp9 has a unique and
significant effect moreover because
there is anc on these earbuds you get an
even more isolated sound and better
sound performance now this is going to
be a little bit more subjective but the
anc here for me at least is a solid 10.
all right it works great it does the job
very very well and with anc you can
choose between high or low noise
cancelling here and at the other end of
the spectrum you have ambient sound mode
which slightly lowers the music volume
and uses the three microphones so say if
you're listening to music at full volume
and you still want to be able to
maintain a normal conversation it does
that and say you're busy in the kitchen
or you're at the gym and your hands are
tight well there's a text to speech
function that reads your alerts and
notifications to your earbuds as well
very very handy loving what lg has
thought about in terms of software and
hardware on this so far next up we have
microphone quality and with the triple
mic setup it does a pretty nice job of
picking up your voice even in the
noisiest environments this is the lg
tone free fp9 microphone test with very
little ambient noise hello hello she
sells three shelves by the seashore
nailed it
very good very enjoy and this is the lg
toll-free fp9 wireless earbuds
microphone test with
pretty noisy ambient sound blink in the
background what do you think of the call
quality you think it's good let me know
down in the comments below so as you can
tell i have one earbud near my mouth to
speak softly on the phone even though we
have a very noisy background and this is
the beta set of functions you can try on
the tone free app under the tone free
lag section
what the whispering mode does is to make
this right earbud super sensitive so if
you come upon a moment when you need to
have a private conversation and you're
out in public
this is a neat function to have
i'm secretly in love with justin bieber
so what about when you're using them for
gaming well there is a slight audio
delay when hooked to the dual sense
controller and lg knows it so they edit
a game mode which reduces the audio
lengthy of the earbuds now so far i have
not experienced any audio cutouts but
this will also depend on the device you
are using still another neat function
coming from the fp9 and while the tone
free lab is experimental we can expect a
lot more tweaks and extra functions that
might roll out officially so i'm excited
to see what's next for the fp9 all in
all for a pair of earbuds that cost 298
singapore dollars the fp9 have impressed
me through and through and you can
probably tell by now it's got an
abundance of unique features like anc
good battery life and the ability to
connect devices without bluetooth with
that said if charcoal black isn't your
cup of tea the lg tone free fp9 is also
available in perl white and haze gold
and you can get them through lg's
official brand stores on chris shop
lazada shoppi and authorized retailers
which you can check out in the
description below alrighty
i'm gonna wrap up this video what do you
think of the fp9s are you gonna get them
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below and while you're
there consider giving us a like and
subscribe to this channel till next time
this is zacky
adios
[Music]
you